this propaganda video has been aired in
recent days on north korean tv
kim jong-un is showing off his
equestrian skills riding at speed on a
white horse
but it is the speed of progress his
country is making with its nuclear
weapons and missile programmes that's
worrying diplomats
there were nine missile launches in
january a record in a month and the most
recent launch was an advanced
intermediate range ballistic missile
ambassadors came to a closed-door
meeting the third this year before it
even started though the chinese
ambassador made it clear he felt there
was a vicious circle and the u.s needed
to do more invoking the summits that
president trump had held with the korean
leader in 2018 and 2019.
they should come up with more attractive
and more practical more flexible
approaches
policies and actions
we have all seen we have all seen what
happened in singapore
we have all seen what happened in hanoi
china and russia wouldn't agree to a
joint security council statement at this
stage that clearly angered eight other
council members which came up with their
own statement read out by the u.s
ambassador the cost of the council's
ongoing silence is too high it will
embolden the dprk to further defy the
international community your chinese
colleague said that the us needs to do
more and he specifically referred to the
hanoi summit and the singapore summit
which president trump had with the
supreme leader kim
so is it time for president biden to get
directly involved in the diplomacy the
united states has made clear that we are
willing to meet with the north koreans
without preconditions but before we can
commit our president to meeting we need
to have a better sense of what there is
to achieve the united states would
clearly like the security council to
take a tougher stand on pyongyang but
china currently actually wants to ease
sanctions on north korea and it's a
subject that will come up again on
monday when the security council under
the presidency of russia holds a meeting
about sanctions around the world james
bays al jazeera at the united nations